la devo smettere di fare dentro appena
sveglio però è vacanza e sono pigro non
rompetemi l'età siamo su ultimate
chicken or so che il gioco che ho fatto
la settimana scorsa però stavolta c'è
anche pietro vi lascio al video perché
sono ma stavolta vi ho fatto un culo
così bella adesso tutti scegli il
personaggio io scelgo il cavallo sei un
[ __ ] nostro obiettivo arrivare alla
alla bandiera
ok dobbiamo ostacolarci noi stessi
perché devi arrivarci pagheranno gli
altri arrivo la bandiera vince sono
ostacoli che anche tu puoi peccare di
occhio ok ok
vai vai vai parti allora il primo che
arriva in genere è avvantaggiato e sono
caduto
se vincono tutti il punto nomina
assegnato a nessuno e non ci crede morta
la pecora vada deficiente ok io sono
terzo se diciamo tutti nessuno prendeva
niente perché quando si prende un po
vero ostacolo diverso certo certo
gli ho fatto di tutto perché tanto non
posso neanche io come stop è raro che tu
sei una merda
la messa lì all'inizio a posto ha fatto
benissimo io metto sempre un ostacolo
all'inizio sono morti tutti ma a quanto
sò forte siete andati sotto guarda
quanti non perché adesso non solo non
solo il finale ti dà punti anche
uccidere gli altri con le morto subito
quella pure vai anche tu che devi grazie
money money money money money money
ma non è vero
ciao pietrino ciao
no no sto dicendo sbagliare c'è un
esempio solo quei ragazzi grazie mille
guarda quanti quanto mio stracciati se
il altrimenti il cavallo questa è stata
la partita più breve che abbia mai
giocato in genere sono molto più lunghi
e procede scarsi come la morte quindi
opera prima perché abbiamo inter dare la
prima cioè anche quest'anno già fatto
però mai con gente mi del cartoon buco
nero so io sono loria vuoi lombardo
hummer data è va bene ma vi pare moriamo
anche noi nessuno arriva il palato è
possibile ci provo da colpe sono morti
si arriva mostra rilazi sono arrivato
del giorno sono passata non sa dove c'è
no ma basta già e già è difficile
stupido secondo mora anche da paese
ho vinto non è vero ma dai è fortissimo
ci ho fatto a cagare nel primo video che
sono fuori di testa rimette tutti gli
ostacoli esistenti al mondo dal temibile
morirai
vuoi ma gli occhi rivedo mai è legato
carire cartonato trappola schifosa light
ah che palle
è nota è impossibile no no la trappola
che in essa di e fotte tutti ma come
ciao amici amici
no questo pensavo ci possono delle punte
antù kodomo no non paesaggio questa
volta che scrivo di me basta che roba
che sei
[Musica]
amore non può il ore da loro non coi
miei amici miei salutate la vittoria dà
una possibilità sia ridicola come ballo
perché è che con call con calma con
calma mamma mia se va bene si faccia
dare aiuto come non punti ora non avanti
dai no che è successo lost ci ha escluso
dalla partita
9 sapete perde siete delle play cruz il
7 dei pusillanimi sapete neanche perdere
come i bambini o che si sa che questa
l'ho mai fatta cosa c'è e va pero dai
pietro non aver timore un pollo io
volevo una società si basi può scalare
sta roba che non si possa fare solo
salvo alla nave
l'hack è male alla testa forte dietro da
fuori e mori come mori come si solidale
morì anche troupe uomo nofollow
ritrovato solo io ci voglio credere
non ci posso dire pensione lori ultimo
[Musica]
anche che la casa l'inizio turno sei
stato tu lamenta all'inizio nodi o
aiutando la donna brutta clero
bellissimo stavolta no no
quante scemo colti agli occhi ma come lo
sei morto ciao o muori sto tizio
maledizione vabbè dai miei che sono così
come è andato a prenderli dentro è
andato dentro libro non sapevo tensione
anch'io vado che si facciano presa mamma
è scemo e scemo e scemo che vi storia ma
non ci credo io tra l'altro sono passato
prima perché ho ammazzato è che sono
solista vinto solo io
vai marco anche se non è che se ci
riesci a fare in genere chi si aspetta
adesso vicinati che non credono
se no no ho preso la freccia in pieno
nella new eyes è rimasto solo più vaio
dato che aspettare gli altri è una
tattica che funziona sua volta perché
arrivi ultimo
ma come mamma o no la prima una bomba
quella profonda quella fortuna ancora
accade salvato
adesso il procione ha capito la quarta
volta che muore ma passa a stare lì che
non vedo niente
esatto è la tattica loretta vieni amico
pieni vieni qua a te lo onorerà con
calma non mi piace questo giorno e c'è
mica un coso è caduto tra preso in fiera
solista o anche ammazzato delle persone
molto probabilmente quindi ho preso
molto di più
solista no no nessun ammazzato per il
crocione per il procedimento per le le
mani e via il procione la pressione ce
l'ha fatta insieme
no l'ho presa presa presa era come il
pullman a scuola non lo prendo mai
non è vero
ok ragazzi troppo forte oggi troppo
forte oggi prego pietro prego gravissimo
visto che bravo perfetto preso anche due
chili di trappola chamava questo è vero
dentro media disintegrati a tre su tre
ne ho vinti incredibile su una sedia
vuota cliccato fuori andiamo sui tetti e
mai dovegiocare.it ebeti allora il
giorno in cui mi alle 16 gli avversari e
appunto gli avversari tutti a volte
erano molto più forte di me
grazie al mezzo alle scale esattamente
lì dove non fastidio per niente nessuno
ha preso il punto da rosa pesca sta
succedendo all'elefante non ancora vinto
e morto cosa hai idea di quanto sarà
difficile stavolta hai fatto io rimango
fermo direttamente non faccio niente di
buono è morto io vi ammazzati e tutti e
due amichevoli forte quanto riguarda
guardano e muori signori grazie a tutti
grazie yo yo sterminati in un colpo alle
52 mm punti anno quando mina volta mamma
mi un fenomeno sto gioco
no non vale sei morto no come sentiamo
tanto sul traguardo non è vero mai ci
voglio credere mai nella vita hai vinto
solo c'erano parole ti sei fruttato sul
traguardo perché l'aquila cosa ti ha
colpito da lanciatori e una donna magari
ci voglia credere che victoria brutta e
via pietro è forse arrivato ancora un e
vincolare non puoi vincerlo non puoi
vincere non è vero vantava come sapevo
non saremo mai come non ci possa
arrivare file aiuto non ci si può
arrivare i capitoli può vincere
ho vinto no no valore ho vinto nella
maniera che non è possibile mi ha
schiacciato e mi sono passato da un
buchino fa schiacciare i tasti dal
bookie aspetta aspetta
no non credo sei morto metà tra visto
prima io anche tu sei riuscito però si
stato bravo a paolo va bene e stato
bello ragazzi un gioco da ragazzi e dire
che possiamo concludere qui video è
stato bello c'è un salto soddisfacente
poi ve ne sia piaciuto costruzione di
preciso quanto mi piace che lui faceva
schizzare sono questi ed iscrivetevi noi
ci diamo ma non possiamo ragazze
[Musica]